it was in Pennsylvania that the
predicted Red Wave was revealed to be
little more than a trickle
in a crucial Senate race John fetterman
overcame both a stroke and stiff
competition from the trump-backed
celebrity Dr Mehmet Oz giving the
Democratic party a Fighting Chance of
keeping control of the Senate
and President Joe Biden has welcomed the
preliminary results while the press and
the pundits are predicting a giant red
wave
it didn't happen
and I know you were somewhat missed by
my
my obsessive optimism but uh I felt good
during the whole process I thought we
were going to do fine in the 1994
midterms President Bill Clinton lost 52
House Seats in 2010 Barack Obama lost
63. this year the loss could be in the
region of 20 making Joe Biden one of the
most successful first-term presidents in
recent history
the major Republican party Victory came
in Florida
which has now emerged as a fully
Republican stronghold and we're in a
strong showing Governor Ron DeSantis
easily held onto his position
confirming his status as the most likely
Challenger to any possible re-election
bid by the state's most prominent
resident former president Donald Trump
it'll be fun watching him take on each
other President Biden also took note of
a noticeable change in voter
demographics
voter registration figures and the
results themselves indicate a huge
increase in the number of voters between
the ages of 18 and 30. stirred it would
appear by the desire to combat climate
change and an anger at attempts to stop
a woman's right to choose
it also reflects that the president of
future Generations impatience and anger
at the political ranker of the past Mike
Hannah Al Jazeera Washington